Well, if I don't raise my power status again today,
I'll be S-ranked soon, and I'm in the
middle of the day.That's bad, but don't disturb
me.Princess Margaret is at work.Princess
This world is amazing that there are even princesses.That's it.  I'm
making an air box. Air box. Well, there
are times when no items come out even after you defeat a monster. I'm
sure in general,
Nihonium's monsters
seem like useless dungeons that don't drop anything at all.  Apparently, they discovered through research that they
drop air. That's
when they came up with the idea of ​​packing air into boxes and selling them. It's
not just air either. It's
Princess Margaret's handiwork. It's an
amazing idea to shake air.
This is the company's main product
[Music]
This is the princess exchange.I can
carry a lot of magic cards at once, and I
can't have the princess going back and forth to the dungeon, so I can
reduce the back and forth.  That alone will make things so much easier. I've
always wanted a magic card, but it's an expensive
purchase, so I
have to discuss it with Emily.